[Music]
if you want trophies everyone in
football knows you send for Joe's a
Mourinho but something he's not worth
the trouble
often bringing unwanted baggage with the
silverware like falling out with his
star players Tottenham Hotspur already
have one of the best training facilities
in Europe and now they think they have
the manager to match
Mourinho unemployed since leaving
Manchester United last December already
taking his first training session even
staying overnight here Spurs have barely
pushed her it's your butcher team out of
the door before they announce the
appointment of his successor a man who
divides opinion wherever he goes it
won't be a surprise to me at all if he
gets him into the top four because the
crowd they're gonna be up you know and I
think he's got to start well he's got to
get the crowd on side I can't wait to
see his press conference he's gonna
charm the pants off all the Tottenham
fans and they're gonna love it and I
think it's gonna be an exciting time
Spurs took 14th in the league and
chairman Daniel Levy is bargaining on a
sprinkling of Marino's undeniable stuff
power to turn things around I was I
think I'm a special he is a specialist
in Fela I'm not
I want more premierships alone than the
other 19 managers together three for me
but is Mourinho still the full-si boots
was and will he be worth the money it's
certainly the most expensive era in
Tottenham Hotspurs history they've just
built the 1 billion pound new White Hart
Lane Stadium and now they're spending a
reported 50 million pounds a year on
Josie Marino's wages that's in addition
to the 13 million pounds they've had to
pay to terminate the contract of
Mauricio posh Tino and Mourinho will
demand money for new signings during
less than two years at Manchester United
he had a net spend of 370 million pounds
fans are wary of the potential this deal
has to turn toxic but most remain
hopeful
you love him or hate him but I think at
techno we need some trophies with the
situation we've got at the moment with
the squad we've got I think he's
definitely the best appointment the best
to get something out of them someone
wins us the Champions League I think
he'll be our stature outside this ground
we'll be that loved today is to do and
Tottenham Hotspur are hoping this
signing is worth the risk
Martha Kellner Sky News